I'm in the eighth grade I'm only
240 pounds at this point anyway he's not
I mean he's a buck 40 or something and I
was like leave me alone and I'm like
getting scared I don't remember how we
got into it but I ended up grabbing him
and just like ragdolling him against the
the the the lockers like
and he's like
like losing Consciousness and like blood
coming out of his nose and ears and my
guidance counselor Mr Bourgeois was like
running down the hall going William stop
but also kind of laughing and then you
know brought me to his office he's like
you're not in trouble but try not to
don't use your shirt yeah it was sort of
that weird like you know oh we have this
uh we have this uh with this pet bear
and it's really nice and and then it
forgets that it's playing and just every
once in a while knocks someone's
head off foreign